ok bon voilà ce que je veux mettez-moi
trois chocs de whisky avec un call car
pour faire baisser un coca zéro bien sûr
je fais gaffe à ma ligne
dina tu sais qu'on a seulement venir
deux wagons au bain alors dans ce cas
servait moi tout de suite les trois
chutes de whisky et apportez moi un choc
de bailey's dès qu'on aura atteint
l'altitude de croisière elle va t'y
connais tout de suite et apportez moi un
peu caché riz tant que vous y êtes
dinars 1
serait-il possible de baisser d'un ton
on pourra tâter de la [ __ ] ce week-end
tu devrais apprendre ce qui doit sortir
de la bouche d'une phare et toi ce qui
doit y entrer eux c'est bon c'est bon
essayons de nous limiter à la méthode de
lisa pour la maman non sérieux
franchement lisa c'est quand la dernière
fois que tu t'es fait ramonet la
tuyauterie
j'sais plus deux ans peut-être bien tu
es sérieux depuis terrance tard qu'est
ce que tu veux je m'occupe c'est vrai
quoi je fais du spinning extrême je lis
des livres ultra érotique et j'ai
investi dans une pomme de douche
surpuissante hat est amovible qui me
donnent beaucoup plaisir figure toi ou
génial ton histoire vient de me faire
entrer en ménopause
voilà je suis presque prête
françois
ah attendez une minute
qu'est-ce que vous plaisantez j'espère
j'aime vraiment cette tenue je vous
signale que c'est du cousu main de la
broderie y voyez-vous fabriqué par une
tribu du guatemala quasiment éteinte
quoi il n'y pas au guatemala tu veux que
je te dise les hommes raffiné issus du
beau monde apprécie réellement ce genre
de tenues très bien les coups tu tu es
magnifique merci beaucoup mais elle
retire ça en vitesse et mais ce truc
cette robe c'est c'est une moustiquaire
en fait
du coup peut-être que t'attrapera
quelque chose oui un homme à porto rico
c'est super à la mode chez les grands
mères tu voir les mecs peuvent payer
n'importe quoi mais nous apprend avec
ses fringues pas la peine chez au
courant des termes si tu pouvais ne pas
passer la soirée à faire des tas malaise
crier elle avait vraiment pété une
durite ça me plait qu'ils aient la fée
teinte de retour parmi les elle est
hôtesse vraiment du gâchis de ne pas
exploiter toute cette énergie
tu disais moi tu disais que ce serait
vraiment du gâchis de ne pas exploiter
toute mon énergie
tu es en 1811 texte
n'a jamais douté n'ai jamais lu les du 2
au 15 août ils peuvent le faire je
déchire jeter scheer le jour la nuit en
boucle non-stop déchets en excellence
aurélie way tombeuse way
que faire quand il commence à te
remonter les organes il va lui virer les
toiles d'araignées la famille des choux
fleurs